it's always nice to find money you
didn't expect for most of us
maybe it's stuck in our couch or an old
wallet but for the state
it's unexpected tax revenue today
governor sisalek says nevada
actually has 600 million dollars more
than projected
hector mejia live in the newsroom this
afternoon with the details on the
state's economic forum hector
in the last 14 months we've had to deal
with covid restrictions changing
constantly the governor
said the sacrifices we've made during
that time gave way to this increased
revenue projection governor steve
sisolak addressed the state virtually
from carson city
saying nevada is in better shape
economically with 586.2
million dollars more to spend than
initially projected
he also credits crisis management and
strategic decisions
over the summer the governor convened a
special session to close a 1.2 billion
dollar budget shortfall
which included depleting the state's
rainy day fund there's still a long way
to go as nevada
tries to recover as we move forward
systemic urge leaders to think about
individual families
yesterday's economic forum showed us
that those in our state who make the
most
were impacted the least and those who
make the least
were impacted the most we will not
recover
if we do not use these funds to build a
state that gives them every opportunity
to succeed
systelac said those opportunities should
include expanding child
care helping small businesses and
investing in community-based
services he said this is an opportunity
to rebuild
and change the state's huge reliance on
tourism
systelac also gave an update on the
vaccine rollout saying as of today more
than 45 percent of eligible nevadans
have received at least one dose
and more than one-third of those who are
eligible in the state are now fully
vaccinated
in our newsroom hector mejia 8 news now